the audience frequently will write in or
ask me questions or call in and talk
about Canadian psychology professor
Jordan Peterson and I've answered a lot
of those specific questions about claims
that he's made about contradictions or
double standards that he's espoused
we've also interviewed Jordan Peterson
on the show it was back in 2017 and I've
expressed some of what I think about
Peterson and about what he does but in
this video I want to go deeper and sort
of flesh out some of the more general
thoughts I have about the movement
surrounding Peterson he's seen as
relevant in some online spheres of
political discussion so I think it's a
good opportunity to go through some of
this stuff and really think about it so
as far as some of Peterson's actual
positions again I've refuted some of
those in the past and I'll probably do
that in the future as it comes up
whether it's some of his confusion about
post-modernism or undervaluing the
utility of collectivism or how he plays
these epistemological games when it
comes to religion and I definitely
disagree with him about many specific
social and political issues and I'm sure
that I'm gonna get some comments after
this video where people will say David
you didn't actually debunk Peterson's
political positions or his
socio-cultural positions or his actual
views on specific issues here you're not
really refuting what he says that's not
the point of this video okay in this
video we're going to talk about Jordan
Peterson himself and his movement and
some generally concerning and
hypocritical elements of it and to start
with it's really important to understand
that Peterson denies being a
right-winger even though he constantly
denounces collectivism egalitarianism
political correctness identity politics
feminism all of which are typically
associated with leftism he's a big
proponent of right-wing and conservative
ideals like hierarchies traditionalism
individualism capitalism and that's fine
right I mean Jordan Peterson can be a
conservative political pundit but he
won't take all
of it now maybe he thinks that he can be
more effective at pushing this ideology
or agenda if he's able to avoid being
labeled as someone who's merely on the
right I don't know that's a possibility
but what's especially silly is
Peterson's complaints about being
thought of as a political figure at all
right he accuses people like many
journalists of unfairly associating him
with politics and of framing him as a
political commentator and framing his
messages as political and that it's the
fault of the journalists that that's
happening you never really thought of
yourself as a political author and and
public figure but that is how and as
I've been saying you know as we've seen
so much of your messages about is the
personal it's how you as an individual
can behave and take responsibility but
yet you are being painted in a political
light do you see yourself as a political
figure
not particularly no but it everyone that
I'm interviewed by virtually insists
that that's what I am right well but the
reason for that is that most of our
dialogue in mainstream media I would say
is always focused on political issues
and so if you have a hammer then
everything looks like a nail right it's
so nice to see people concentrating on
psychological and philosophical issues
and leaving the idiot politics as far
behind as possible because it's
certainly uh what would you call it a
distraction and a dangerous one at that
so it's so funny talking to the
mainstream media types because
everything they talk about has to be
viewed through a political lens and
although I continue to insist I did BBC
HARDtalk which was aired today and that
was a classic example of an interviewer
being entirely scripted and trying to
push everything that's happening around
me I suppose
into a political narrative Peterson has
this attitude of political what humi
political like he's not involved in the
realm of politics and that this is how
people are wrongly or unfairly trying to
paint him now I can think of a ton of
non-political public figures who go on
news Pro
and aren't asked political questions and
don't answer political questions because
they genuinely don't have anything to do
with politics
that's not Jordan Peterson right
individualism versus collectivism that's
a focal point of Peterson's commentary
and it's also one of the foundations of
politics and of people's existence in
one place or another of the political
spectrum and then even more explicitly
Peterson discusses hot-button political
issues like Canadian human rights law
American presidents Canadian Prime
Minister's immigration policy climate
change economics Marxism in equality
including wealth inequality the
relationship between poverty and crime
and on and on and on and he does it on
public popular platforms like his own
YouTube channel on Joe Rogan's podcast
in interviews with journalists in
corporate media so it's absurd for him
to claim to be bothered by people
associating him with politics or people
discussing the political implications of
what he espouses and then more
importantly discussing politics is what
made the guy famous in the first place
right why is he even so popular first of
all he's very effective at tapping into
the anti social justice warrior thinking
that's happening in the minds of many
young people whether these young people
were previously on the right or on the
left or just people who didn't really
think too much about politics they were
to some degree annoyed by perceived
political correctness on their college
campus or on social media Peterson has
regularly uploaded videos to YouTube
since 2013 but he really grew in terms
of the size of his following when he
became this outspoken aunt is JW
activist political activist I would
argue in late 2016 early 2017 around the
issue of transgender pronouns if it
weren't for that vocal opposition to
transgender pronouns two years ago he
likely wouldn't have the following that
he now has it's all predicated upon this
political issue on which he commented
and there's a huge market for that right
now it is much easier as I've talked
about before to become popular and to
make money online if you're doing this
anteye sjw anti political correctness
content than it is creating any other
type of content in the sphere of
politics and social criticism especially
on YouTube which is where Peterson
became prominent I shouldn't say this
but I'm going to because it's just so
goddamn funny I can't help but say that
I figured out how to monetize social
justice warriors it's so funny I just
can't believe it either way but Peterson
is also popular because he gives advice
about personal development that's often
quite good he talks about alienation he
talks about how to find meaning in life
and some of Peterson's critics on the
left I I believe strongly should just
admit that Peterson is talking about
serious issues and he's communicating
real practical ideas that can help
people but it's really important to be
able to distinguish his competence as a
psychologist from his ideologies that
are very wrapped up in politics just
because Peterson offers possible
solutions to common dilemmas that a lot
of young people particularly young men
face when they enter adulthood and when
they try to find their place in the
world that doesn't mean that by default
everything Jordan Peterson says about
politics or philosophy has to be true
the ideologies that make up Peterson's
worldview like Jungian psychology and
fervent individualism are not the only
ideologies that can inform most of the
advice that Peterson gives so what
happens in practice is that Peterson
fans will start taking his reasonable
advice it understandably has a positive
impact on I would say they're probably
his life or sense of self-worth as the
disproportionately men that follow
Peterson which is fine but then he makes
the fallacious assumption that what
Peterson is telling him to do is
inseparably tied to Peterson's
philosophical and political outlook
Peterson's fans will often assume that
because the advice about finding your
place in the world is good and useful
because Peterson's personal worldview on
those issues is true that the politics
of Peterson are the only possible cattle
of that advice and of that ideology in
reality Peterson's giving universal
non-controversial advice which is
espoused and accepted by many world
views often world views that are in
direct conflict with Peterson's politics
helping people improve their personal
well-being for lack of a better term
their self-esteem or their interpersonal
relationships some might argue this is
the point of being a clinical
psychologist which is Peterson's
profession there are many clinical
psychologists who could start YouTube
channels and build a following and help
lots of people even if you want to argue
that Peterson is better suited for it
that he's exceptionally good at
communicating some of these ideas to
young people even if that's true it
still isn't proof that his ideological
perspective is more valid than any of
many other countless other frameworks in
psychology and philosophy that can
result in positive outcomes for people
that are tied to totally different
political ideologies there are totally
different schools of thought that have
done lots of good for people and are
backed up by decades of academic
justification but if Jordan Peterson's
lectures and his views on psychology
resonate with you and help you I don't
want to discount that what I want to do
is remind you that Peterson is not the
only game in town and we should be
careful about thinking of him number one
of some kind of omniscient guru but
number two about thinking of him as
someone who is able to give this non
controversial fairly obvious advice
because of his views on politics
including individualism a Galit arianism
collectivism so on and so forth and you
can tell that this thinking exists in
part from the anger and the
condescension with which Peterson fans
argue against anybody who criticizes him
I've experienced this right some
criticisms of Peterson are unfair and
people should push back against unfair
criticisms of Jordan Peterson it's good
to have reasonable debate about public
figures but the level of passion and
dedication that you
in the Petersons fans on social media
scares me because of how it extends
beyond the rational to the totally
emotionally irrational consider this
question why isn't there an astronomer
or a computer scientist or a historian
with a fan base that will fight to the
death for their claims the way many of
Peterson's fans do for him it is because
many peterson fans have this sort of
deep tribal even spiritual connection to
the guy and his movement in his
teachings and the intensity of
Peterson's defenders goes beyond the
so-called facts and it goes into
feelings and into emotion and into
loyalty that extends beyond reason what
the peterson fans need to understand is
that this type of devotion is partly
what fuels the unfair criticisms of
peterson it's a circle when a public
person has a huge group of zealous
attack dogs who pounce on any critic of
the movement the movement becomes more
fun and attractive to criticise to
outsiders now I'm not saying it should
be that way but without question this
kind of cringy fanboy behavior of so
many peterson fans is itself what turns
people off of jordan peterson people
shouldn't
strawman peterson people shouldn't
criticize peterson dishonestly but the
adoration of his fans is part of what
feeds it and you might say oh that's
unfair and I'm agreeing with you I'm
saying yeah that is unfair but there are
many peterson fans who would benefit
from being a little bit more self-aware
one of the most disconcerting things
about peterson fans is how seriously
they take themselves something that
open-minded people with a sort of
healthy diversity of intellectual
influences rarely do they rarely take
themselves so seriously most people
actually learn to become embarrassed
about taking themselves so seriously and
they eventually grow out of it which may
be some peterson fans will do so to be
clear I'm not saying Peterson's doing
anything to proactively encourage his
fans to act this way
I've seen videos of people asking
Peterson what he thinks of the idea that
he's becoming a sort of cult leader and
his explanations of why he doesn't fit
the definition do make sense
I'm talking about the fans themselves
and their cohesion and their
aggressiveness and groupthink
that's what we should really be paying
attention to so I said it I said I said
the word cult let's talk about that a
little bit strictly speaking it's not
accurate it's not productive to say that
the Petersons movement is a cult per se
but if you're a Peterson fan and
Peterson was your introduction to
philosophy or to psychology or to
self-improvement and you know far more
about Jordan Peterson that about any
other public intellectual or similar
figure it would be useful to examine
that and to sort of broaden your
horizons but this is predictably
understandable in a way Peterson's
following is largely young men going
through the same things that young
adults have gone through for a very long
time existential crisis the need for a
moral code strategies for dealing with
daily life and relationships and anxiety
and sort of finding purpose and your
place in the world these are natural
voids that surfaced when we become
adults and we realize that we're
responsible for our own actions and for
our way of life and we've got to make
sense of it all right but we should be
really cautious about filling those
voids totally or mostly with one
person's advice that's always a bad idea
because we can become sheep and accept
everything that that person says without
skepticism or without enough skepticism
and then you end up in this position of
many Peters and followers which is that
you think anybody who criticizes that
one person must be an idiot and must be
attacked on social media the way we're
seeing critics of Peterson attacks
here's a key point
many jordan peterson fans don't realize
that the good advice they're getting
from Peterson and the positive outcomes
that they might experience by applying
his advice to their lives aren't the
products of Peterson's way of looking at
the world a lot of what Peterson touts
is universal and you can arrive at the
exact same conclusions and ideas through
many paths Peterson's values are one way
of framing it his fans receive this
universally applicable set of truisms
and very obvious advice
package
within Peterson's philosophical and
political views about post-modernism and
feminism and political correctness and
his fans end up thinking that the advice
they get from Peterson is inextricably
linked to those views when it's not
Marxism and political correctness are
bad and individualism is good and Carl
Jung was a genius and mythology is
important therefore I should clean my
room and stand up straight and not tell
lies and make friends with people who
want the best for me
that is the key distortion of this
entire movement Peterson ties the advice
into his ideology either deliberately or
implicitly but most of the advice that
he dispenses is not controversial it's
not unique it's not novel and when
people find the advice powerful and
useful they adopt the rest of his
ideology or they assume that since
Peterson was right about standing up
straight he must be right about
everything else for many of the Peterson
fans that I've spoken to personally it's
a matter of thinking I'm lost in life so
I'm going to go with the self-help guru
that seems to share my belief about how
lame social justice warriors are or Wow
okay look he's got a lot of great advice
on his YouTube channel I'm enjoying it
he clicks with me in a way that no other
intellectual has so I'm hooked into the
entire political milieu that he's
espousing it would be really useful for
the Peterson fans to ask themselves why
are they infatuated with this one person
and not with any of the other
psychologists doing great important
scientific work is it actually the
content of what Peterson is saying or is
it that they're sort of mesmerized by
his YouTube videos and is delivery when
it's the latter this is not his capacity
as an academic
it's his role as a de facto spiritual
leader that is impressing people and
that's where it goes in the cult-like
direction so there's an irony when
Peterson talks about the importance of
thinking for yourself Peterson gives
fans a way of feeling smart without
actually having to thoroughly study the
intellectuals that Peters
sites much less the countless
philosophers with viewpoints that
directly contradict Peterson in really
credible and important ways being a
loyal unquestioning Peterson fan doesn't
really demand much of you right it's
easy many in Peterson's audience are
relying on his interpretations and his
conclusions about philosophical issues
and current events without doing much
thinking on their own and that's what
gurus do and enable their followers to
do
Peterson's fans like to claim that he
uses cold scientific facts to back up
his arguments Peterson presents his
arguments about gender culture economics
politics whatever as hey facts are facts
science has already decided and the
Peterson fans get hypnotized by this and
they develop this attitude that anybody
who disagrees with Peterson's
conclusions and theories must just be
inherently arguing against reason or be
afraid of science or not care about what
the so-called facts are without actually
verifying the cited facts and the
theories outside of Peterson's own
singular word when you combine that with
Peterson's traditionalist moral outrage
which constantly says in in sort of
summary our society is heading in a
dangerous direction and I'm fed up with
it it has the ability as it has done to
mobilize people who feel disenfranchised
by scaring them about a society that's
supposedly changing for the worse and
then it creates this common monolithic
enemy for the Nazis it was the Jews for
Trump voters it was Mexicans and the
Chinese and liberals I guess who knows
for Petersons fans it's this radical
leftist postmodernist neo-marxist figure
which as is often pointed out is really
a concept that Peterson has crudely put
together incorrectly by conflating all
of those movements but that's actually
for another video not for this one but
the main idea is that tribalism becomes
their source of energy banding together
not only against the supposed
postmodernist neo-marxists but against
anybody who critiques Peterson at all as
we've seen on our show they might love
arguing for Peters
positions but they equally enjoy
rallying together against Peterson's
detractors and what binds the Peterson
movement more than anything is this
camaraderie that comes from their
indignation toward anybody who's not
part of their movement or who criticizes
their movement there's nothing wrong
with defending and ideology against
opposing viewpoints the red flags in the
Peterson movement are the group think
and the unquestioning allegiance to a
single guru like leader so the big
picture advice that I have is diversify
your sources of so-called wisdom being
guided by an eclectic mix of thinkers
and ideologies might be more confusing
it'll definitely be less straightforward
it will be more messy as I like to say
it will require you to sort things out
for yourself instead of having your
worldview spoon-fed to you by one person
but that's what it means to be a free
and critical thinker and that's why I
encourage you to do it